[Musique]
et cette invité ce matin c'est vous en
redsaenberg merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin vous
êtes secrétaire général du Secours
populaire
d'abord il y a un peu plus d'un mois
vous avez publié Votre paramètre votre
baromètre pardon de la pauvreté et de la
précarité en France on a vu ce reportage
sur la situation des étudiants français
plus globalement en France la pauvreté
s'accélère sur votre baromètre accentué
par la crise du covid et désormais par
la hausse des prix dans cette enquête il
y avait 38% des Français qui estimaient
avoir déjà connu une situation de
pauvreté est-ce que ça s'aggrave et
est-ce qu'il faut craindre que la
situation ne se détériore davantage avec
ce contexte économique qu'on est en
train de traverser
oui la situation s'aggrave
nous l'avons signalé dans toute la
France puisque nous sommes sur 1300
lieux sur le territoire
il n'y a pas de diminution des
situations de pauvreté il y a de
nouvelles catégories de personnes qui
sont touchées et sont concernés
aujourd'hui aussi fortement les enfants
c'est ce dont témoigne le sondage Ipsos
auquel vous faites référence
ceci étant ce n'est pas parce que la
situation est celle-ci que l'on doit
s'incliner et baisser la tête il doit y
avoir une mobilisation de l'ensemble de
ceux qui peuvent agir bien sûr ceux qui
sont en charge mais aussi dans la
population il est possible d'aider son
prochain il faut essayer de ne pas se
limiter à se regarder le nombril et il
faut agir et il faut voir quels sont
ceux et celles qui ont envie de se
mobiliser avec vous pour faire reculer
cette situation il n'est pas normal que
dans un pays riche comme la France des
personnes et fins il n'est pas possible
que des personnes
âgées qui se sont portées caution pour
leurs enfants aux petits-enfants qui
n'ont pas retrouvé de travail et qui
sont appelés à financer les dépenses qui
étaient des dépenses de consommation
courante
qui sont aujourd'hui en situation de
revenir vers le Secours populaire pour
dire écoutez on fait ce qu'on peut pour
nos enfants pour nos petits mais nous on
a faim c'est la France d'aujourd'hui
donc nous sommes tout à fait limpide sur
le sujet chacun peut le voir chacun et
chacune il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux et
de regarder son prochain donc pour ce
qu'on peut plus l'air cette question est
de toute première importance nous
faisons ce nous demandons Ipsos de faire
ce travail de sondage depuis plusieurs
années et donc les questions sont les
mêmes ça nous permet de voir les
évolutions nos pensions que après la
covid la situation allait se stabiliser
et qu'on avait passé
la réalité nous montre que telle n'est
pas le cas et et nous ne nous
flagellant pas pour se faire
nous disons chacun doit prendre sa part
et c'est la démarche jusqu'en populaire
de collecter de l'argent de collecter
des moyens matériels en direction de
tous ceux qui peuvent y contribuer et de
créer les conditions de l'espoir pas
simplement de s'enfermer dans son
malheur et de ne pas attendre alors une
aide de l'État mais vous leur dites quoi
au pouvoir public face à ce qu'on nous
disons au pouvoir public qu'ils sont en
charge c'est-à-dire c'est pas nous qui
sommes en charge sont eux qui sont en
charge ils sont en charge de
l'intégralité de la population et
évidemment de ceux qui sont les plus
fragiles mais après c'est à eux de faire
le travail pour ce qui concerne le
Secours populaire nous nous le faisons
sur le terrain avec les personnes dans
les quartiers dans les campagnes dans
les zones rurales dont peu se préoccupe
et nous pensons que ces deux la
population que
le soutien peut venir à partir du moment
où chacun accepte de regarder l'autre et
pas simplement de se préoccuper de ce
qu'il reçoit sur son smartphone c'est
pas seulement une question technique
c'est une question d'attention à l'autre
et de respect de l'autre et d'appel la
responsabilité de chacune et chacun pour
nous c'est très clair et de surcroît en
ayant cette démarche nous voyons que ça
marche donc c'est pas simplement une
idée théorique comme ça qui viendrait de
je ne sais où c'est que on l'a vérifié
chacun peut le vérifier il le fait avec
le Secours populaire ou avec d'autres
mais il le fait à son échelle à son
échelle vous parlez de regarder l'autre
ça fait écho évidemment ce titre ne
jamais baisser les yeux ce livre que qui
est paru tout récemment la semaine
dernière chez Robert Laffont à la fois
le récit de près de 60 ans d'engagement
un constat donc de l'état de nos
sociétés de la solidarité comme de
l'injustice un hommage également au
fondateur du Secours populaire français
Julien lopetre décédé en 2019 pourquoi
ce livre pour un passage de de relais au
suivant
alors pourquoi ce livre en fait c'est
une proposition de l'éditeur c'est pas
une idée à moi d'accord c'est clair ceci
dit j'ai entendu la question et la
proposition et il est clair que c'est ce
type de parole pas seulement la mienne
ce type de parole doit pouvoir être
relayé pour que chacun sache qu'il peut
agir et la question c'est pas le relais
au sens où on passe un témoin et ensuite
on rentre chez soi c'est chacun peut
agir et sépare ses actions convergentes
élaborées ensemble et en partant de la
réalité des situations des personnes qui
l'est possible d'être efficace c'est pas
le modèle a raison et la réalité à tort
parce qu'on peut plus l'air on est
intéressé par les modèles mais on sait
que ce qui compte c'est la réalité et ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est quand le rendant
visible tangible et en montrant
l'efficacité ça donne envie à d'autres
de s'y joindre et ça concerne toutes les
générations c'est ça c'est plein
d'exemples extrêmement concrets ça passe
par les bidons villes de
Champigny-sur-Marne à ceux de de
Kinshasa en passant par Gaza qui Gali
Beyrouth Katmandou la Haute Volta qui
est le Burkina Faso aujourd'hui
sous-matra après le tsunami le Mexique
l'Ukraine aussi pas celle d'aujourd'hui
mais il y a peu comment est-ce que vous
parvenez à vous détacher des causes de
la misère pour vous attaquer aux
conséquences en gros est-ce qu'on n'a
pas parfois envie d'agir plus en amont
est-ce que ça vous révolte pas ces
situations
peut faire l'analyse qu'il veut les
causes ça appartient à la conscience de
chacun et c'est à chacun dans décider
mais en ce qui concerne les conséquences
celle là elle s'impose à chacun et
chacune d'entre nous et on peut pas
parce qu'on a des avis divergents sur
les causes rester sur son avantin et ne
pas se préoccuper de la vie quotidienne
par exemple j'ai rencontré hier l'un de
nos partenaires burkinabés ça
préoccupation aujourd'hui en plus de la
situation que chacun connaît c'est de
pouvoir disposer de tracteurs pour
pouvoir en semencer plus vite du fait
que le phénomène climatique se traduit
par le fait que les pluies sont moins
longues et bien cet aspect là il vient
du terrain il vient du Burkina Faso et
là solution immédiate pour les paysans
c'est par exemple d'avoir des tracteurs
qui leur permettent en communauté
paysannes de pouvoir travailler la terre
plus vite et plus largement et donc de
pouvoir semer plus vite
plus largement et de pouvoir récolter
plus pour la population ça c'est très
concret c'est le rapport direct entre
l'expression des besoins et la
possibilité de faire et donc nous allons
voir avec qui nous pouvons discuter pour
pouvoir leur envoyer c'est 4 tracteurs
anciens parce que ils ont besoin de
matériel qui puissent réparer eux-mêmes
autrement dit nous ne dissocions pas les
sujets nous partons des besoins des
personnes nous collectons les moyens
pour ce faire et nous réalisons avec eux
et nous rendons compte et eux nos
partenaires dans les différents pays ils
rendent compte autour d'eux des sources
du fait que ce sont des hommes des
femmes des enfants des jeunes qui à
d'autres lieux de la planète ou sur
d'autres lieux de la planète ont
collectait les moyens pour les aider et
du coup nous contribuons à faire que il
y ait des relations qui s'établissent
entre les uns et les autres qui sont
liés à la vie
et qui sont porteurs d'avenir c'est tout
le message de ce livre créé du lien de
la compréhension entre les peuples vous
revenez également sur votre parcours le
combat de vos parents rescapés de de le
low cost et qui vont qui vont vous
enseigner ce message de solidarité
envers les autres
vous parlez notamment de cet exemple ou
dans les années 60 ils abritent des
mineurs en grève chez vous vous disiez
mes parents manqués d'argent donc ils
avaient encore plus ceux qui ont manqué
comment est-ce que vous expliquez que
ceux qui viennent en aide au plus
nécessiteux ne sont pas aujourd'hui les
plus aisés
alors c'est une c'est une grande
pratique et on le lit dans toutes les
philosophies de tous les pays du monde
et de toutes les époques donc on n'est
pas dans une nouveauté ceci étant ce que
je dois dire et pour le Secours
populaire c'est extrêmement important
c'est que en plus de ceux qui donnent
avec le peu qu'ils ont il y a
aujourd'hui des personnes qui ont plus
de moyens pour des raisons diverses et
variées et qui se disent que peut-être
ils peuvent aussi être concrets et aider
sur les mêmes sujets et nous faisons
appel à tous nous ne faisons pas le tri
les seuls décisions négatives du Secours
populaire porte sur le fait qu'on
n'accepte pas d'argent du trafic humain
et du trafic de drogue
c'est quand même assez limité c'est
extrêmement puissant sur le plan moral
mais ça veut dire que tout le monde ou
que ce soit peut agir il peut agir en
France avec le scorpopulaire français il
peut agir avec nos partenaires sur tous
les continents parce que le Secours
populaire n'installe pas des secours
populaires français ailleurs puisque on
est dans l'Hexagone mais en revanche il
recherche partout des partenaires qui
ont la même démarche d'aider ceux qui
sont autour de et de rechercher les
moyens pour se faire et donc il y a
aucune contradiction c'est le fait de ne
pas avoir d'argent n'est pas une gloire
le fait d'en avoir beaucoup n'en est pas
une non plus et c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est comment chacun peut agir
avec sa conscience avec son efficacité
et en relation avec les autres pour ce
qui nous concerne l'altérité et le
respect de l'égalité des personnes qui
qu'elles soient et d'où qu'elles
viennent c'est l'un de nos fonda et ce
que je dois redire c'est que cette
démarche est efficace et qu'elle marche
il y a de très nombreux cas de figure on
se dit on a essayé on a essayé ça marche
pas nous quand ça ne marche pas on
cherche comment ça va marcher et on y
arrive et je ne peux qu'inviter tous
ceux qui l'entendent à y contribuer et
c'est un conseil après 60 ans
d'expérience au Secours populaire merci
beaucoup Henri Salberg d'être venu chez
nous n'être mourir et faire quelque
chose entre les deux c'est votre message
toutes ces choses que vous avez faites
et ces combats que vous avez mené et que
même le Secours populaire c'est donc à
retrouver dans ce livre ne jamais
baisser les yeux seaux éditions Robert
Laffont merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin